[...]
SPEAKER: In many countries,
it is against the law
to hire a woman to be a surrogate
mother, to carry a pregnancy for pay.
Some US states permit the practice.
But the total cost is around $100,000,
more than many couples can afford.
Seeking a more economical
alternative, many couples
from Western countries
seeking surrogates now
go to India, where
paid pregnancy is legal
and a source of employment
for rural women.
Indian women receive
around $6,000 to $8,000
for caring a pregnancy, about
one-third of what surrogates in the US
are paid but more than the Indian
surrogate mothers would otherwise
earn in a lifetime.
Suppose it were up to you,
as an Indian legislator,
to decide whether to permit or
to prohibit commercial surrogacy.
How would you vote?